- Pediatric Epilepsy Center of Excellence.
And quite appropriately, he
is going to seize the day
with this talk.
So Dr. Sullivan. (laughs)
(applause)
- So as much as I love
that preliminary title,
there was a slight tweak.
The content is exactly the same.
So thank you for inviting me back.
I think this is the third,
or maybe fourth time
that I've spoken, sort of
an every other year basis.
And often in my field, there
is in the pediatric epilepsy
space, there's often not
a whole lot of change.
And so I always rack my
brain, like what am I gonna
talk about that is going
to engage the audience?
So I'm happy to say that this
is an extremely exciting time
for pediatric epilepsy.
I know this is not just
a pediatric conference,
but we all know that
children do become adults.
And so everything that you
will see in my presentation
applies to adults.
And I think it's an exciting
time because we are finally
getting some attention from industry
to start looking at a
lot of the unmet needs
that our patients have
with ongoing seizures.
It's often been very challenging
as a pediatric provider
when new drugs come to the
market, to really understand
what role could they play in
some of our pediatric patients.
And especially these patients
that I'm gonna talk about
today, that have some of
these, in the big picture,
rare syndromes, but rare in the sense that
I guarantee everyone in
the room has had one or two
of these patients sort
of cross their path.
So with that...
So these are my disclosures.
Some of these are relevant,
because I am under contracted
research for some of
the data that I'm gonna
present to you today.
So my objectives are first,
to recognize some of the key
clinical features of epilepsy syndromes,
to then describe how those
syndromes can evolve over time.
I often say that this is
one of the most fascinating
things about my job, is I
get to follow a moving target
that is a developing child's brain.
So just because we actually
have one seizure type
that may present in infancy,
as we continue to follow
that child over time, things
can change and evolve,
and therefore our treatments
need to change and evolve.
And then, the real, the meat of this talk
is really gonna be to appraise
the data behind the novel
antiepileptic drug therapies in some
of these specific syndromes.
And just to sort of jump
ahead, one of the things
we're gonna be talking
about is Cannabidiol.
And so you would probably
have to be living under a rock
if you had not seen in the popular media
of cannabis based therapies,
and we finally do have
some data to support its use.
So first, what is an epilepsy syndrome?
So this is kinda the Holy Grail
for a pediatric epileptologist.
There's no term that makes
me want to have a seizure
more than the term seizure disorder.
You know, cardiologists, no
one tells a person who has
an arrhythmia that you have
a cardiac rhythm disorder,
or someone with diabetes that
you have a glucose disorder.
So we want to use the term epilepsy.
Epilepsy still has a lot of stigma,
the term still has a lot of
stigma associated with it.
But in my opinion, the only
way that we're gonna get
around that stigma is
to start using the word
in its appropriate context.
But an epilepsy syndrome
even goes beyond that.
It actually gets to these
different bullet points.
So the age of onset, the
different types of seizures
that that patient may be
having, the EEG patterns,
and then what we call
the interictal condition.
So what are these patients
looking like in between
their seizures, right?
We focus a lot on, what
does a seizure look like,
how long does it last,
how do they act afterward.
But equally important is
how are these patients
doing in between?
Are they completely normal with
no intellectual disability?
Are they somewhere on the
intellectual disability
spectrum and where?
And why, why would some
of these patients who have
a normal brain MRI and a
normal EEG have moderate
to severe intellectual disability?
So that is a very important
piece of the puzzle.
And then really, the
explosion that is continuing
to change our field in 2019 is
the genetic characterization.
So we are now fairly...
It's fairly easy now to
get an epilepsy gene panel
on most of my patients.
And it really is, by looking
at all of these different
salient clinical
features, that we are able
to discover new epilepsy genes.
So why?
Is this just something
that I can come up here
and have a couple slides,
to be able to speak about,
and make myself sound smart?
No, absolutely not.
If someone calls me on the
phone from the Emergency Room
and says, "Joe, I have
one of your patients here
"with Dravet Syndrome",
which is one of the syndromes
we're gonna talk about,
that already paints a clear
picture in my mind of probably
how that child presented,
what medicines they're on, what
medicines they may have been
on before, and what I need to
actually be thinking about.
So not only does it lead to
a more accurate diagnosis,
rather than my cringed
seizure disorder term,
but it really does lead
to improved management.
It leads to targeted workup.
And often times, I think
we can actually limit
our workup, right?
We no longer need to
embark on what I would call
the shotgun approach of
working up these patients
for rare inherited metabolic disorders,
when I was in training, not so long ago.
And we actually can start
to suspect these specific
diagnoses on clinical grounds.
It also helps with
counseling and prognosis,
and certainly helps
with genetic counseling
in terms of risk to
future siblings or risk
for that specific patient's children.
So we're just gonna go through
really a couple of cases,
just to keep you engaged.
I guess just the pleasure of speaking
directly after lunch.
And these will, maybe
these different cases
will start out being familiar,
and get a little bit less
familiar as we go on.
So case one is an eight
month old male infant
with normal birth history who
presents to the pediatrician's
office, where mom's saying
he's starting to have
those startling, like he was a baby.
The episodes occur most
often upon awakening,
and they don't occur in isolation,
and they last 15 minutes.
So the first thing that
we hear from parents,
what do you mean it's lasting 15 minutes?
So you have to actually ask.
Is the entire event lasting 15
minutes, or is it an on off,
is it a cluster of these events?
And so as it turns out,
when you ask that question,
it's a cluster, so these
startle spells are happening.
The individual spells themselves
only last a few seconds,
but they're clustering
over a 15 minute period.
The exam is completely
normal, and unfortunately,
no episodes are witnessed.
So the pediatrician very
rightfully had a concern
for about what this diagnosis
was, and sent them in
for video EEG monitoring, and
I'll play this video here.
So you'll see a baby
with pretty normal tone,
nice flexor, the arms and legs here.
And then we see this
little startle slash crunch
slash spasm, right?
And you'll see, this kind of
occurs almost like a metronome,
we can kinda count a few seconds here,
and then there's this,
this sort of adduction of the arms,
and flexion at the hips.
Completely in between these episodes is
actually completely normal.
If you could see his face,
he's actually, eyes are open,
he's very awake and interactive.
Eventually, the parent
comes over to the side
and pushes the button
to let us know that this
is the clinical event of interest.
You'll also notice that
it's fairly symmetric,
so this is where we, in the
EEG lab, start to geek out
a little bit, and say,
"Oh, did that left arm
move before the right arm?"
We do these types of things.
But these are pretty symmetric.
And the reason why we
geek out about that is,
is if we have asymmetric
spasms, we start to wonder,
is there something, you
know, on the opposite side
of the brain in terms of
malformation of cortical
development, or potentially a brain injury
that could be driving this process.
So this is this child,
actually this child's EEG.
I always say to my
trainees, this is maybe one
of the only EEG patterns that would be
on your pediatric boards.
So this is hypsarrhythmia.
And the important thing to note here...
Is there a pointer, is this it?
Oh yeah, great, wow, that's a big pointer.
So hypsarrhythmia, basically,
the blue is on the left side,
and the red is on the right.
Hopefully you can appreciate
that I could turn this
upside down and it wouldn't
look any different.
That's not how a baby's EEG
is supposed to look like.
And the other take home point here is that
hypsarrhythmia is an EEG
pattern in between seizures.
So this is the pattern
that these poor children
are living with 24 hours a day.
The seizure is this, it's
this one second period.
And so you can imagine, so
why would these one second
seizures lead to the
intellectual disability that
the majority of these patients
ultimately go on to have?
It actually doesn't, it's
not this one second seizure.
It's the other 23 hours
and 55 minutes a day,
that they're EEG is looking
like this firestorm of activity.
So, this specific condition,
while we want to treat
the patient, about 95% of the
time in pediatric epilepsy,
this is a case where not
only do we want to treat
the patient, ie the
seizures, we also want to try
to normalize this EEG as
quickly as we possibly can.
So I gave it away, this
is Infantile Spasms,
also known as West Syndrome.
And I'm just gonna sort of go
through this schematic here.
This is all in the syllabus,
I'm not gonna go through
every single line, but
I wanted you to have
all this data to refer to.
The hallmark are these extensor spasms.
The EEG pattern is
classical hypsarrhythmia.
One important point is, let's
say that we did that EEG
and the EEG was normal.
The question then is,
did you capture sleep?
You actually, early on in the
diagnosis of Infantile Spasms,
if you just do a waking
EEG, the EEG can be normal.
You have to be sure
that you capture sleep.
And so you haven't
captured sleep, that's one
of the reasons why we often
just admit these babies,
so that we can actually
get a prolonged recording
and record sleep.
The etiology has really
not changed over the years.
The top two are either
malformations of cortical
development, or neonatal encephalopathy,
usually due to some prenatal
or perinatal insult.
But the list of genetic
disorders that are potentially
causal for Infantile
Spasms continues to grow.
What I'm gonna talk
about next is really how
our treatment has evolved.
The mainstay of treatment
is still steroids,
either ACTH, which is the injectable,
is an injectable medication,
or high does prednisolone,
and then vigabatrin.
And what I'm gonna show you
is some data that is really
making us realize that
this is one of the few,
what we call, pediatric
epilepsy emergencies.
It's akin to a child coming
in with a new diagnosis
of leukemia, and we want
to throw the kitchen sink
at them, literally, almost
like an induction therapy,
to try and not only
control their seizures,
but to try and normalize that EEG.
You can see here that the spasms actually,
even left untreated, will often go away,
but then it's kinda like the
damage has already been done.
So this is one sort of alarming
study that just tells us
that even in 2000, this was
18, in 2019 we can do better.
So they surveyed 100 patients
with infantile spasms,
and then they looked at
the time to the visit
with the first, what we
call, effective provider,
which would really be a child neurologist.
The median time was 25
days about, so already
three weeks have passed,
and only a quarter of them
were evaluated within the first week.
And this really is our goal.
We know that earlier is better.
And the common theme
here was that the moms
usually would say, "Something's not right,
"something's wrong", right?
And if there's one thing that
I remember from pediatric
residency, always trust the mom, right?
If something's wrong,
you better be worried.
And then the respondents
stated that pediatricians
and neurologists were
basically just unfamiliar
with infantile spasms, so
hopefully as you go home today,
you will no longer be unfamiliar.
And then, where this
is important, I think,
is this is a paper that just
came out about a year ago,
in Lancet Neurology, really
looking at that sort of
induction sort of approach.
We're not only using...
Up til five years ago, we
would start out one treatment,
steroids, that didn't work,
we'd move on to the second
treatment knowing that there's
a high rate of relapse.
This group actually looked
at, what if we just threw
both the hormonal
treatment, which we classify
as the steroidal
treatment, plus vigabatrin.
And it turns out, this
is pretty much almost
the highest spasm free rate
that has ever been reported
in the literature, compared
to hormone therapy alone.
And the reason why this is
important, because if you can
get these patients, more
patients spasm free and get them
spasm free sooner, we
know that that leads to...
Well, like all things in
neurology, it's dependent
on the underlying cause.
If you have someone with
really severe brain injury,
that's gonna be ultimately what predicts
how they do developmentally.
But in those kids that
maybe have Infantile Spasms
of unknown cause, the earlier
that we can get them under
control, translates into better
outcomes in terms of IQs.
And you can ask questions,
we'll have a sit down here,
about each of these sort of scenarios.
So case number two, moving
up a little bit older
into the age spectrum.
So a 10 month old female
with normal birth presents
to your office after
coming to the ER for their,
after their second febrile seizure.
The first seizure was
at six months, two days
after their vaccines,
and lasted 15 minutes.
So already, a few red flags there.
Six months is a little young,
15 minutes is a little long.
And then the seizure last
night was 10 minutes,
and only appeared to be
on one side of the body,
and she was diagnosed
with acute otitis media.
So someone may look at
this and be like, you know,
10 month old normal baby, two
or three febrile seizures.
Febrile seizures are common.
Reassurance, don't
worry about it, go home.
Hopefully at the end of
this talk, you will realize
that that would be an error.
So development is normal,
starting to cruise,
having mommy and daddy.
No family history, and
neurologic exam is normal.
So this is Dravet Syndrome,
so this is something
that I have, has become one of my clinical
and research interests over
the last six or seven years.
I'm gonna go into some
of the clinical trials
that basically have led to the approval
of novel medications.
And I would argue that had
these drugs not been studied
in this specific syndrome,
we may not actually
have them available to us today.
So the core phenotype for these children
and what makes it, I think, so challenging
to make the diagnosis,
you really have to have it
sort of on your radar
screen, is that it usually
occurs in normal kids between
five and eight months.
Their initial seizures
often are prolonged,
but don't always have to be.
And the normal development,
right, that's the one thing
that often makes us just feel reassured,
that it just can't be one of these
genetic catastrophic epilepsies.
But then it's the evolution, right?
The seizure epilepsy
syndromes tell a story.
The subsequent months, you
start to see more febrile
seizures and afebrile seizures.
And then there has been an
association with the seizures
occurring in the setting of vaccine.
The patient still should be vaccinated.
The vaccines do not cause the syndrome.
And people have actually looked at this,
and there is no different
between those patients
that are vaccinated,
unvaccinated, or whether or not
their seizures occurred
proximate or not proximate.
And then again, these patients,
they evolve over time.
And so, there's a bit of a
sort of menu approach here,
that was published about 10 years ago,
that if you basically...
This was before you even see the patient.
You can get all of this over
the phone from the parent.
So if their fist seizure
occurred less than seven months,
if they've had five seizures
before their first birthday,
that's five points, and
if any one of the seizures
was prolonged, that's seven points.
All you need is six points
to strongly strongly suggest
that one should order targeted
gene testing and suspect
the clinical diagnosis of Dravet Syndrome.
I would actually argue,
if you are unable to get
genetic testing, do not
be afraid to still give
a person this diagnosis.
This is still a clinical
diagnosis, because about 20%
of patients who present
in the exact same way
will still not have a
mutation in the SCN1A gene,
but that does not mean they
do not have Dravet Syndrome.
So I think this is a very
helpful sort of ratings scheme
to sort of help us determine
when we should suspect it.
So the reason why I feel
I wanted to talk to this,
like Dravet Syndrome, yes it's rare.
It occurs in about one in 15,000 patients.
That's rare, but not that rare.
Is that this syndrome, in a
study of pharmaceutical grade
purified Cannabidiol, published
in the New England Journal
just two years ago, as
the pivotal study that led
to Cannabidiol's approval
as an entiepileptic drug
just this past October.
And so in this study, they
actually enrolled patients
who had Dravet Syndrome, you can see this
is a severe epilepsy
population at baseline.
They are having about 12
convulsive seizures per month.
And the two groups were
equally represented here.
And then if you look in those
that received Cannabidiol,
it went down by about half,
compared to no change in placebo.
And then when you take into
account all the statistics
and what not, the overall
median reduction was about 39%
compared to 13% placebo, which
is statistically significant.
But I would actually argue, it is also
clinically significant, right?
You have someone who is going
from 14 seizures a month
down to six.
And so, I had lived the sort
of era of before there was
a pharmaceutical grade
of Cannabidiol happening.
I had so many families
coming in, what about CBD,
what about CBD, what about CBD.
And we just really didn't know, you know?
I think all of us felt that it worked,
but it was really anxiety
provoking for the caregiver,
as well as the physician to say,
"Yeah, you can go to the
store, or you can go to Amazon,
"and drop this in your basket,
"and it might be CBD, it might not.
"Just try a little bit
and if it works, great."
So this is a sort of, a very well known
adult epileptologist
that wrote an editorial
to this manuscript, saying,
"Cannabinoids for epilepsy,
real data at last."
so this kinda shows a
little bit more specifically
how these patients,
all these patients did.
So the green line is actually a placebo.
The blue line is the treatment group.
And you can see the number
of patients that had
a 50% reduction in seizures.
So the drug differentiated
itself from placebo,
at all sort of treatment time points.
And then you can see, some
of these didn't actually
reach statistical significance.
But again, parents and families don't care
about statistical significance.
If their kid is the one
that gets the 75% reduction
in seizures, they don't care
if it's a P value of 0.1.
But this was enough to get it approved.
And so we're excited to
actually, to have that
as a treatment option.
So next is this drug
that you will very likely
be hearing about this fall.
It was just submitted to the
FDA as a new drug application,
again, for the treatment
of Dravet Syndrome.
I wish I had time to go
into the whole story,
but essentially, the reason
why this drug fenfluramine,
which was one of the active
compounds in the Fen-Phen
diet back in the 90s,
was even being considered
for Dravet Syndrome was
really by complete accident.
It was just that a group
in Belgium had started
a few kids back in the
early 90s on fenfluramine
for behavior issues,
who also had epilepsy,
and their epilepsy improved.
And then they went back
and looked at those kids,
and lo and behold, many of
them had Dravet Syndrome.
And so this launched a
whole renewed interest,
of could this actually be a drug that has
more widespread
antiepileptogenic potential.
And so very similar study design was done,
and the demographics were very similar
to the New England Journal
paper that I just showed you.
Average monthly seizures
were somewhere between
25 and 40 convulsive seizures per month,
and this is the data.
So this is the percent
reduction in seizures,
compared to placebo.
So placebo's already included into this.
So 64% reduction in the high dose group,
and a 33% reduction in the low dose group.
So keep in mind, these
are patients that have
a very very high seizure
burden, and really
have already exhausted most, if not all,
of the conventionally
available antiepileptic drugs.
And in the median number of
drugs that these patients
were actually on, you had
to be on a stable drug
regimen to enter the study,
was somewhere between
two and three drugs.
Furthermore, this is what I...
Because I was one of the
investigators on the study,
this is the slide that I love to show.
Because, you know, 50%
reduction, yes, that's great.
But there's a lot of drugs
that result in a 50% reduction
in seizures, especially in
our refractory patients.
But how can we do better than that, right?
Can we really push the envelope a bit?
And so for the first time,
now we actually have 45%
of these patients having a greater than
75% reduction in seizures.
So now we're getting
into treatment effects,
which I think are life
changing for these patients
and their families.
And then lastly, what
about seizure free, right?
Have we given up on seizure freedom?
Just a few years ago, my opening, sort of,
when I made the diagnosis
of Dravet Syndrome,
I would tell families,
that you really need
to reset your expectations,
that seizure freedom
is just not really an achievable goal.
I still think that
that's probably the case
for most patients, but in this study,
we looked at how many
patients actually were either
seizure free or near seizure free.
The unfortunate thing is
in a study, once you have
a single seizure, you
can never then again be
seizure free from that intervention.
So we said, what about in this 14 weeks?
If someone was having 25 seizures a month,
and then they had one
seizure in three months,
that's almost as good as seizure free.
And in this high dose group,
it was 25% of patients,
and in the low dose,
13%, and none in placebo.
So again, these are
the data that are being
submitted to the FDA, and it
was just submitted in February.
And we hope that this drug
will get approval this fall.
Okay, case number three,
this is the last case.
So, a little bit older kid,
and you'll see a little bit
of a theme here.
So a history of Infantile
Spasms who responded
favorably to treatment.
Someone gave them the combination therapy
of steroids and vigabatrin.
But then the mom started noted
that when we was standing,
he would have an abrupt fall.
And she would also notice
that when he was sleeping,
it would appear as if
he was trying to sit up
or stretch and his whole
body would stiffen.
The history was significant
for developmental delay.
He did not start walking until 20 months.
And the sort of salient features
of his current development,
well he had no expressive
speech, but was able to follow
some simple commands, such
as pointing to body parts.
So here's a video of one of his seizures.
You can notice the helmet, so
already there's a little bit
of a red flag that
something's going on here.
Okay, so it's pretty quick.
I'm gonna go back, sorry, go back.
So you can see, luckily,
mom was standing there
and holds him, okay?
And so again, as the epilepsy
specialist that likes
to geek out and play these
videos in slow motion,
what do you see?
You see a head drop, right?
So if he was standing in
the middle of the floor,
he would have fallen.
But also, hopefully what you can see...
We'll play that again.
Is arms.
Arms go up, right?
So this is not a pure
atonic seizure, right?
Is there a little stiffening component?
Is it actually a myoclonic component?
And so, for the purposes of
studies and study design,
we basically as a pediatric
epilepsy community,
decided to just lump all these together
and to drop a tax, right?
Because it's a seizure type
that would result in a fall,
and these are the
seizures that are the most
disabling for these patients.
So then, different child, but
again, back to the other type.
So a little, what we see there is...
Stiffening that kinda
clusters a bit, right?
And so one other sort of pet peeve of mine
as an epileptologist,
second to seizure disorder,
is that every single
seizure that someone sees
is a generalized tonic clonic seizure.
It's almost like it's one
word, generalized tonic clonic.
(laughter from audience)
In fact, the minority
of seizures that occur
are actually generalized tonic clonics.
So you have to think about what that is.
Generalized, so both sides.
Tonic, stiffening, clonic, jerking, right?
In this seizure, right, we see tonic.
We see the stiffening,
and I can play it again.
We don't necessarily see the clonic.
Now, this could be
confusing, because, you know,
is that he's stiff, and
then there's a little jerk,
and then he's stiff again.
But once you've seen a
tonic clonic seizure,
you will know that this is not that, okay?
So this is pretty much a
cluster of tonic seizures
that occur during sleep.
And so what is this syndrome?
I must have left out my answer there.
This is Lennox-Gastaut Syndrome, okay?
So Lennox-Gastaut Syndrome,
again, it occurs...
It's these epilepsy syndromes
that are evolving over time.
So they occur a little bit later,
with a peak around age three to five.
The hallmark are these
tonic axial seizures
and atonic seizures,
which I just showed you.
Many other seizure types can occur.
The EEG often has characteristic findings
of what we call slow spike and
wave, or these fast activity.
The etiology is often
very similar to Infantile
Spasms and West Syndrome,
and in fact, a very high
percentage of patients
who have West Syndrome
will evolve into Lennox-Gastaut.
The treatments are sort of
the broad spectrum medications
that hopefully you all have heard about.
But now, one that's entering
on to the scene is Cannabidiol,
because I showed you
the study of Cannabidiol
with Dravet Syndrome.
The same company did a
similar study in a group
of patients with Lennox-Gustaut Syndrome,
and here are those, here's those data.
So again, we're looking
at the drop seizures,
so it doesn't matter if
you stiffen then drop,
or if you just drop, or
if arms go up and drop.
If you drop, you drop.
And there's a very detailed
definition in these protocols
that you can imagine, like,
well, what if the head
just nods a little bit,
and so you can imagine
the challenge in trying
to design these studies.
And it's all based on parental
or caregiver observation
that is determining the primary endpoint.
But what you can see here
is that these patients
also had a very high percentage...
I didn't include it in here, but,
it's about 80 seizures per
month, these patients are having.
And so you can see that in
the placebo, there still
is a placebo responder
rate that's quite high.
So what is the placebo responder rate?
I wish I knew.
My theory is that this is
just the background noise
of what happens in a
unpredictable disorder,
that is epilepsy.
And if you can imagine,
if someone's head drops,
and the parent had their
head turned, they may not
be able to count every
single seizure reliably.
But we do have to
demonstrate that these drugs
can be superior to placebo.
But you can see that there
was, again, a 40% reduction
in the higher dose group of
20 milligrams per kilogram,
although not dramatically different.
So the package insert
is basically saying that
you should try to get to this dose,
and then if it's tolerated
and you still have more,
if you still want a chance
at additional efficacy,
you can increase the dose.
Again, looking at all seizures,
acknowledging that some
of these seizures are even
more challenging to account,
there did seem to be a change.
And herein lies the problem.
So non-drop seizures, so
these are the seizures where
the kid stares off into space,
maybe drools a little bit.
Is that a seizure?
Maybe, maybe not.
And you can see, the placebo
responder rate here is 35%.
And I think this just gets
into why those seizure types
really can not be counted
in some of the primary
outcome measures for these studies.
And then again, this
looks at the 50% reduction
and the 75% reduction, so 25%
of patients in the higher dose
group of Cannabidiol had a
75% reduction in seizures.
This also was not
statistically significant.
It's in the manuscript,
so I put it up here.
But again, if you look at it,
it's dramatically different
than what was achieved in placebo.
So I think it's something
that is at least reasonable
to hope for in this highly
refractory patient population.
So to conclude, hopefully I've shown you,
at least in these three
epilepsy syndromes,
that they can evolve over
time, and it's our job
to educate families,
caregivers, other health care
providers, of what to expect.
So if I have a patient
with Infantile Spasms
who responds to therapy, I will tell them
that, you're not out of the woods yet.
Be on the lookout for some
of these other things.
What I think has really
been exciting is that these
specific epilepsy syndrome
diagnoses have allowed,
not only allowed, but
they've engaged more interest
from the pharma community to get into this
niche epilepsy space.
And it has allowed them to
design these clinical trials
with that specific population in mind.
And that, this I guess is
my hanging up my shingle.
If you have a patient who
is not responding to drugs,
and they have not seen
an actual epileptologist,
in my opinion, they really need
to be referred for at least
a one time evaluation, to
see if we can have somewhat
of a tailored treatment approach.
Thank you.
(applause)